We have a song which we teach in class to help people remember the names of
the major dynasties.
Right.
It really does help to know which dynasty comes before which.
So we're less concerned with the dates than we are with the chronological
order, the sequence of dynasties.
Can you sing that song?
I cannot sing it as well as you can.
[SPEAKING CHINESE: ni chang ba (please sing for us!)]
Well, shall we sing it together?
Only if we sing it together.
OK.
[SINGING: Shang Zhou Qin Han, Shang Zhou Qin Han,
Sui Tang Song, Sui Tang
Song,
Yuan Ming Qing Republic, Yuan Ming Qing Republic,
Mao Zedong, Mao Zedong...]
So if you sing this song once a day, you will always remember the sequence of Chinese dynasties.
It works.
It's guaranteed.
You will also drive your friends and family crazy.
It's true.